last year with preacher yes I'm sensing
maybe a little nervous about this
project but season two is out is there
we're there nerves are gone you're
feeling good about this I've less nerves
this time for sure we're showing much
less this time which makes me less
nervous we showed the whole pilot last
time this time we show them like we
don't have much so because we just
finished filming the first couple
episodes and we're a show now already so
that makes it less nerve-wracking but
it's still you know you still want
people to like it what can it die hards
expect from season two what are you
gonna give up I think there's a lot more
if you've read the comic there's more
characters from the comic that I think
you will be very happy to see show up
err star and the Grail who are some of
my favorite characters in the comic you
probably don't know I'm talking about
the show itself whether you've read the
comic or not I think it's a very cool
show and I think it's one of the more
unique shows on television and I think
we're in the second season trying to
make it even more one of the unique show
those TV shows do you find yourselves
pushing the envelope more in in tackling
those those sensor boundaries are you
able to now as what mostly about America
is you can pretty much show any level of
violence you want on television with no
real problem whatsoever and every time I
think like oh this is gonna cause a big
problem there's no that's okay that's
horrible
da peel the show this on TV and that's
what's wrong we do that's what's wrong
but we're still doing it and you feel
okay about that I feel great about talk
about doing justice to something you're
a huge comic book fan yeah
and you take a comic book and you switch
platforms with it and you turn it into a
TV show was some pressure a lot of
pressure huge pressure mostly from
ourselves though honestly like we young
we love this comic and we you know just
didn't want to ruin it we just didn't
want to be known as the guys who
couldn't that would suck we took the
thing we loved and destroyed it so yeah
that was mostly the pressure we made a
Green Hornet movie that no one liked but
we didn't particularly like Green Hornet
so it was a good training ground because
we ruined a thing that we didn't
particularly like but that was a good it
was both good training and a good
warning cuz you're like man if we have
like The Green Hornet that would have
been a you know on the tail end of
awards season I think it is over now
someone like ruth negga is the darling
of award season you guys sort of have
her in your project since day one I know
Jeff Nichols did some stuff with her but
you know sort of finding her having her
part of this project
me too you guys it's great it's always
nice when you feel like you've chosen to
work with good people they've decided to
work with you yeah it's amazing that
yeah that she was nominated for an Oscar
and that she completely deserves it yeah
but yet you never know I mean it's such
a total crapshoot that stuff so we feel
very fortunate she's a part of our show
and I think she completely deserves it
all the pre she gets yeah and Emma Stone
beat her we also put in the thing that's
right time which is yeah so Terry and I
never gonna win [ __ ] but you were up I
just age and it was the moment of the
awards with Michael J Fox and DeLorean
there's like the the the sneakers holy
man but a moment in your career yeah it
was it would it would have been much
nicer to be nominated
I take it no it was amazing it was
incredibly cool I love that also we have
to talk about other projects here but
definitely something with Charlize
Theron flat ski your childhood crush
sounds like a horrible project me
involved with someone like that
I know yeah right like a romantic comedy
with me and Charlie yeah yeah it's weird
seems wrong things like that is worth
the price of admission like how did they
make that seem like it would work at a
movie at all that's acting yeah that's
exactly what can we anticipate more
tweets to Donald Trump to president
Trump probably you know so I would
imagine and are you hoping for a reply
one of these days I would love that
slash I'm horrified I just know when I
disappear I think wonton omos he'll open
I don't know if they can revoke your
passport if you were born in another
country but I wouldn't be surprised if
you're born in Canada yeah good yeah
thank God the trump card yes you guys
would take maybe the thing about you is
that you're pushing the envelope with
you know with it the interview with
religion do you seem like you're
enjoying the freedom that you're getting
with these two subjects like it's like
anything goes in a way yeah I mean we
can really you know there's yeah you can
do anything in a way I mean as long as
people as long as it functions
creatively and it has a good story the
characters work and as a whole it it is
a cohesive piece but we we we really
like to write about things that we
personally are interested and talk about
in religion and politics or those those
are the things that we talk about a lot
and so yeah it's fun to try to fold
those things into the the you know
subject matter that were that we're
working on
but also we always try to make it feel
like if you don't give a [ __ ] about that
stuff that we're not ramming it down
your throat either